more than six million american women of
childbearing age have trouble getting or
staying pregnant author michelle t
struggled for three years to get
pregnant and went through multiple
rounds of ivf
instead of focusing on the stress and
anxiety t wanted to share the joy and
humor of her experience as a queer woman
in her 40s she gave birth to her son in
2014 and she writes all about it in her
new book knocking myself up a memoir of
my infertility michelle t good
morning um so your son is seven mm-hmm
why did you decide to write this book
now
well it really felt like now that he's a
fully formed little person who's in
school
um
i had enough time and space from those
early years which it was like one thing
after another you know the whole
struggle to get pregnant through ivf
that whole journey took up a lot and
then suddenly you have a little newborn
and that's your life and so there was a
moment where i could take a breath and
look back on that time with a little bit
of distance and felt like yeah i want to
dig into that so what was the hardest
part of your journey
i think that the hardest part was just
all of the unknowns you know like at
first i didn't even know if my body
could get pregnant
and then i learned that it couldn't and
i was really lucky because my partner at
the time also had ovaries and so i ended
up stealing one of their eggs and you
know going through ivf and doing that
those treatments and that's a lot of
unknowns too you know you're really in
the loop what did you learn about
yourself throughout this journey
i learned a tremendous amount about my
body that i didn't even know i mean i
started trying to get pregnant when i
was 40. so i figured i knew how this
whole thing worked but you know even
something like you know every month when
you you know when you drop an egg i
thought that's what happened you dropped
one little egg and that's you know how
you know you do or don't get pregnant
but in fact the ovaries produce all of
these eggs and then one rises to the top
and slays all the other
right yeah the powerful one so that was
really interesting and it made it really
explained my pms i was like there is a
battle to the death happening in here
so it makes sense yeah what was this
like navigating this process as a queer
woman because that's why i think this
book is so important for people uh to be
inspired by your journey
it was really challenging because
and this was shocking to me because as a
queer person i understood that a lot of
queer people have to seek out you know
artificial reproductive technologies if
they want to start a family so i
expected it to be a lot more
accommodating to queer people and while
the individuals that i worked with at
the clinic were wonderful and super
supportive it was like the system you
know the paperwork the computer programs
we're not so give us an example well one
example was because i was using my
partner at the times egg they had me
listed as a surrogate so all my
paperwork said like surrogate which was
you know no shade on surrogates they're
amazing and doing amazing work but
that's not what you were yeah it felt
really alienating you know to feel like
i was somehow outside of my family and
doing someone a favor so
there were things like that um
and so i was i was really shocked that
they weren't more accommodating your son
is seven now
does he know about sort of his backstory
does he have questions
um
i started telling my son the story of
his birth when he was very young um my
sperm donor is a friend okay and we call
him dhoni like there's your son right
there oh don't eat like auntie
yeah so we you know we say you know
dhoni so-and-so is coming over so that
he always knows that it's never a shock
that this other person was so
instrumental in his existence
and yeah he's always known the story and
only recently i had to explain
sometimes people do get pregnant outside
of a hospital
you know he's like oh i know how babies
happen you go to the you know to the
clinic
yeah there are other ways we'll get into
that someday but yeah what's your
message for people who are struggling to
get pregnant because it is remarkable
how often
i mean we see these stories increasingly
in the last 30 years that it's become
difficult and so what is your message to
those folks who are struggling to get
pregnant i mean it's all you can do is
persevere and be hopeful and try to stay
optimistic you know and and trust sort
of the technology i mean i was really
comforted by the fact that my doctor was
like we're going to get you pregnant
that's not you know we will get you
pregnant feel good that confidence yeah
i mean i was also like but at what
expense you know so it was also a little
like oh you know so uh but i do believe
that the technology works and i've heard
so many success stories from so many
people as a result of doing this kind of
writing trust the process huh yeah
michelle t thank you so much guys
knocking myself up is on sale now